the first thing I think that girls need
to do when they start speaking to guys
and this is in you've met them in a club
or you've like match them on tinder or
you've started chatting to them from
work or whatever it might be when you
first begin speaking to them I think
that girls get too much of a bad rap for
giving lads a hard time and making them
jump through hoops personally for me I
don't think they're making them jump
high enough like I think that the
hurdles that are laid down by girls for
men especially when you're talking 20 21
22 23 and butt up to you know but
throughout the whole way through life I
think the high that the hurdles are as
long as you are making sure that the man
knows that you're interested and that
you're giving them sufficient attention
to know that they're going to continue
to play the game I think it's a win-win
scenario including for the men right let
me tell you why so firstly if you're
laying down and by laying down hurdles
what I mean is not folding or
compromising on something that you think
when they do something wrong you tell
them straight away and you put them in
that place when they make plans and they
cancel them you don't need to go
overboard you don't need to be
passive-aggressive and we'll get onto
that in a second because that is the
number one way to remove the integrity
of what you're saying right passive
aggressiveness for me is up there with
the top knowledge that you should the
girls should do in relationships and
guys at work by laying down these
hurdles for girls the first thing that
it does is it certifies that the guy who
you're speaking to is invested in you in
the long term if they're not prepared to
get past you asking them a question
about their last relationship or you
asking them to make plans for a night
out if you ask them okay let's go out on
Wednesday but I'm gonna let you plan the
date I'll plan the next one but you plan
the day and you turn up when he then
says I've got nothing planned you need
to tell them that he's [ __ ] up you
need to say that [ __ ] that's not that's
not a good investment in your time so
it's the the example there is is having
principal and making sure that the
principal is upheld draw some hard lines
in the sand of what isn't is not
acceptable behavior so I think I've seen
both ends of the spectrum where either
there is [ __ ] testing for [ __ ] testing
sake and it almost is like it's
contrived it's just trying to give
someone hard time for the sake of it but
there's no real underlying principle
very similar to if you've seen the
argument clinic on Monty Python where he
goes into the room he's like hello am I
in the right room for an argument is
like they want you can breathe Leone so
much [ __ ] testing is place for people
yeah the palmistry ultimately well so
yeah let's go on to think of our story
as well but yeah so [ __ ] testing just
what you've said giving someone a like a
hard time or to see how they respond but
yeah it's very good it's the purpose of
doing that though right here only for
that without an underlying it's the
female equivalent of negging right yeah
so so the and what my point is it has to
be a certain agenda and that has to be a
stable set of principles not something
born out of integrity whereas at one
point in the argument clinic he's like
no it isn't yes there's no hang on
this isn't not even this is just
contradiction you like no it isn't yes
it is my fifth argument is a series of
statements formed around a specific
foundational point where as you're just
this on like disagreeing with everything
that I say and so there's the difference
I think like if it's if it's upholding a
certain set of values yes then yeah do
you totally right and that's been done
something that missed and and the other
side of it is just being a doormat it
needs to know it needs to be born of
what you what do you consider as it go
to be acceptable and unacceptable
behavior in a month then draw the lines
in the sand and don't compromise them so
here's the reasons it's good
make sure that the men that you invest
your time in a sufficiently invested in
you because the ones who fall at the
first hurdle and aren't prepared to get
over it what do you think was gonna
[ __ ] happen when they're drunk in a
nightclub and some girl comes up to them
like this is it's making sure that they
can bear a sufficiently heavy load even
a [ __ ] empty bar level of a heavy
load that when they have to go into a 1
rep max in terms of virtue that they
might actually have the capacity to bear
it that make sense just looking at their
bar speed when the bar is empty this is
probably gonna go up we're headed a few
bills there's gonna be like to CrossFit
girls that know so ok so that's the
that's the first thing that's good
before we move on yeah these these
principles if we are for someone who's
listening yeah does this apply so I
think it has to be a conversation of
like
is this person looking for a one-night
stand scenario or are they looking to
move towards about have I jumped ahead
no no you've asked the give us the
perfect question oh because I have
because I think you have to begin with
the end everything if if as a girl all
that you're mapping if you if you if you
want a posting as a girl like crackin
find a guy that is low the barriers what
low the below the barriers but
heightened standards like because if you
wanted one-night stand your parameters
for what you're looking for in a mate
and change yeah in a lecture knew how
bother bothered are you but in terms of
you probably look what someone is a bit
lean you probably want someone who's
muscular who physically fits the
attributes that you need whereas you
know we've all been around beautiful but
stupid people right and vice versa
really interesting people who are not
sexually attracted to and I find that
dynamics so interesting because if you
ask the most women and women if you're
listening and disagree please say but
like any woman I've spoken to you have
asked would you have sex with a man who
you find physically attractive but was
really bored you it was boring of hell
as opposed to someone who you maybe but
you found attractive but you hated and
they prefer to have sex with a man who
they hated because at least the Sun
intensity there's some personal feeling
whereas I think men are much different
in the sense that like you could have
sex with someone that you found quite
boring
I think I'm asked a that tire very
mechanical an interaction was really
women less so much more visceral yeah
man right so perfectly correct if all
that you're looking for is sex then
change your parameters around so this is
a different that's yes I'm talking about
I'm talking about date
I wouldn't say view okay I wouldn't
class dating it's if you need to go out
on the pool mhm then we will do and if
you want a podcast on that then we'll do
a podcast on how to be single like how
this isn't this isn't trading it's
investing this isn't exactly this is no
trading that's not short term positions
this is I'm looking for a long term yes
position for a fact yeah so it's not
very helpful that the wrong crypto is
yeah like yeah yeah exactly you're not
you're not margin trading you're not
doing 50 to expiration
yes exactly so hopefully that made it
much clearer so that's the first thing
that's good right and so it means that
you filter out the bottom feeders mm-hmm
the menu aren't worth your time
and you you jump ahead a couple of steps
so cool
second thing that's good is it sets a
tone for the relationship moving forward
that means that you're not going to take
[ __ ] hmm so we all know and we'll gather
this when we do relationships the proper
relationships podcast for me the key
in almost every relationship it's like
the first six weeks to 10 weeks the
reason being that you set precedent
after precedent after precedent for what
happens in ex situation and why
situation in zed situation what happens
when you don't get a message after
someone's been on the night out saying
that they've got home safe and how do
you react how do you react when they get
in late how do you react when they
cancel a date how do you react when they
do whatever so I forgot to say that
particular camera can only do around
about 20 minutes at a time
every so often okay I'm gonna pass it on
to you I'm gonna have to get up and I'm
you have to change it thanks video guide
Dean um you know pass it on to as when
we speak and then I'm gonna get a prior
to that if you're just listening that's
completely pointless but it's fine so it
sets the tone for the relationship
moving forward to roaming it means that
you are drawing lines in the sand not
only for now that filter out potential
mates
but you're also training them to be a
good mate for you the third and final
one and this is the one that I think is
most holistic moving forward is men
really in fact that I'm gonna make this
into a four thirdly men really [ __ ]
need this
the reason being that it makes them
learn what isn't is not acceptable
behavior for women like if they're if
you are with a guy and you find out that
he's been messaging you mate and you
think that that based on your own values
and your own integrity you think that
that is unacceptable behavior and you've
been him off that's only gonna happen to
him two or three times before he goes I
probably need to change my behavior the
reason that this continues to happen is
that if guys were able to weed all the
way through and this is speaking from
experience because for years and years
and years I was able to outwit girls
that I was seeing to one degree or
another whatever level of depth you want
to say that is mmm and I was able to I
was able to get myself out of it so I
never learned this is the Parkinson's
Law like in a social context of
Parkinson's Law is where you and task
fills at the time that you've allocated
to it and I'm sure if you've been
working to a deadline with an essay or
something you like for some reason you
there's no way you can just kind of done
a week in advance in a two-hour slide
before itch yeah always extends to that
and the same thing like if a certain
behavior is permitted frequently then
you lower your own standards for your
secretaries No so as a man you want
someone to hold you to a higher
standards like Earl Nightingale says the
treat a man as you expect him to be not
as he is and you know give him the room
to expand to that and terraza what our
perfect challenge so that that quote has
managed to make a good synopsis I think
of everything that I've come on with you
so what I think if I had I think as a 21
year old or than younger like 20 year
old I was too
ego driven to probably realize the eye I
think is a young guy you take a lot of
advice like this or I know this is name
to cars in this part or is it look big
Chloe it should be because I should
realize they can make implications from
this mmm the vast majority of the
audience that's listening to this maybe
two thirds of it mmmm oh okay I think
one of the behaviors you've covered
there's a flip side on me to an
interaction and I think that men should
be interested in why women are motivated
the way that they are and women should
be vice versa and men should hold women
to the highest standard behavior as well
just gonna gets it okay oh yeah yeah I
do I think the I think it's hard to as a
guy that age where I think you're
finding your like your own feelings and
your own beliefs in a lot of areas like
this like whatever I think is true in
these situations are forming judgments
based on experiences and someone says
actually women you know a woman should
treat me like this I think a lot of guys
when faced with higher standards or it's
it's sort of a framework that they have
to operate in sort of resist and go for
the person who's not doing that lowest
hanging fruit yeah because it that's
easier yeah but they don't to be
challenged with that but again as girls
do you want to be the low-hanging
[ __ ] for another cause I think
ourselves now we go back we go back to
the first the first advantage that you
get the fact that you filter out the
guys that aren't worth your time and if
again with this there's kind of like a
curve right so one-night stand is this
particular level and then I want
marriage is this particular level and
then anywhere in between there's some
gymnasts and so you can go okay well I
can lay down lines in the Sun that are
sufficiently hard as I need to button
imagine if tomorrow every woman on the
planet
a dear to a similar framework as this
there would be a lone understand that
there would be able to there would be a
lot race sex for a long time but imagine
where men would be in 20 years it's like
it's written on this book don't you want
if you want to have sex with a woman
you have and if you want to be in a
relationship with a woman you have to
learn how to treat it correctly you have
to learn what isn't is not acceptable
behavior and if you [ __ ] up you will be
better for the next woman who comes
around so this is this is coming from a
this whole conversations coming from a
perspective of like women are the on the
victim side of this equation like men
mistreat women that men of the sexual
protagonists and then women give access
so to that women women women female
women that's probably a correct
statement they and a female kind human
females is why men got it human females
are the only females in the animal
kingdom that is sexually selective right
okay so everyone else is just if the
chimpanzees on he she'll mate with the
alpha male mm-hmm but only because he's
they're going given the object given the
opportunity yeah she'll mate with an
email when chessani okay the only reason
that men to the alpha male is because
there's a threat of violence and because
they're because they're available they
expect for us yes and these they will be
obeyed does he's got the biggest man as
he does so
[Music]
you